foreign
I've heard many variations of the story
about the cocaine bear
s I'm okay yes the cocaine bear that's a
very interesting story in himself
one of the most fascinating stories is
the story of Drew Thornton Thornton was
a police officer he was an addict
addicted to Adrenaline and excitement
people say he was as ludicrous as
ludicrous could be at about 70 pounds of
cocaine on him he had a James Bond wrist
watch that shot tear gas a lot of people
know that he was wearing Gucci loafers
well this is very strange
he developed one of the biggest
organizations I've ever seen
thank you
it has corruption murder gun running you
name it
you never believe this happened
[Music]